[Music]
my best friend in high school was Shawn
we would sit together every day launch
skip classes on Fridays to go on a
weekend adventure and surround ourselves
with Weidman snacks when we were
collaborating on our homework
Shawn would carry mathematically gifted
and super cute evidenced by all the
girls would ask me to deliver love
letters in card to him however deep in
his heart he was depressed he was deeply
upset by his parents longtime fights he
was feeling suffocated by the
unrealistically high expectations of his
parents and I was the only person that
he trusted to share his true feelings
with one day after school I bumped into
Shawn's mom I really wanted to alert her
to John suffering but I was afraid the
speaking the truth would embarrass her
and Shan Shan
so I remained silent after high school
Shawn and I went to different colleges
but we stayed in touch then one cold
winter night the second night after 2014
Chinese New Year I received a picture
message from Shawn he had written
happy New Year to me on a frost covered
window then I receive a call from him I
picked up and said thank you so much
Shawn this is so sweet
happy New Year to you as well but what I
heard was Shawn crying uncontrollably
he said that he didn't know how to be
happy in the new year he told me that he
couldn't see a way out of his pain and
he wanted to terminate his suffering
before I could respond I heard some
weird noises and then just silence my
heart froze and my mind went blank Shawn
had jumped out the window of his dorm
I remember how painful it was waiting
outside of Shawn's ICU when a Herschel
parents condemned himself for not
recognizing his fragile mental state I
realized that he had never spoken to his
parents about his suffering and neither
had I when I had the opportunity fear
and doubt kept me silent for three days
I picked my eyes on Shawn's harm on her
screen all of sudden the heart beat
pattern came to a freefall
and turning to a flatline I will always
remember the moment of silence when I
felt so devastated when I realized what
the cause of silence could be
I know this is an extreme case but
perhaps you can relate
perhaps there's been a time in your life
that you've been silent because of your
fear of speaking up at work with friends
in relationship because silence seemed
like the safer choice the silence has
caused where you fail to stand up for
your beliefs you may later feel like
you've lost a part of yourself
and miss out on giving a voice to others
who may feel the same when you hide a
part of your identity for the fear of
not being accepted you may suffer from
never leaving fully and lack a true
sense of belonging when you choose not
to share your true feelings with someone
really care about you may miss out on
potentially beautiful relationship we
tend to think that maintainence does
close safe while making changes is risky
so we're often focused on analyzing the
cause of speaking up without even
considering the cause of silence even I
who have paid such a high price to
understand the cost still found myself
being silent about things that mattered
two years ago on the outside I seem to
have it all I was on a promising career
track with the boyfriend who checked all
the boxes and I would live in Hong Kong
and exciting
new city but the truth was I was very
unhappy in my job my boyfriend's
critical comments always made me feel
inferior and never good enough and for
the first time in my life I was living
by myself with no support group around
me on the inside I felt sad and alone
whenever my parents asked me how I was
doing
I wanted to tell them the truth but I
couldn't I couldn't because I was afraid
to shatter the illusion of my perfect
life I was afraid that something better
didn't exist for me so for nearly a year
I silenced myself and it was painful one
night I lay in bed in complete darkness
I felt hopeless I couldn't see a way out
then suddenly all my memories of Shawn
flooding my mind I thought about his
suffering in silence in the moment when
I lost him forever
and I was reminded of the ultimate cost
of silence
it was at this moment that I decided on
a shelf memory by breaking my own
silence by taking the staff that he was
now able to take I share my frustrations
and my fears with my parents and I was
surprised to find that my being real in
front of them felt so much better than
my trying to be the perfect child and
instead of feeling secure I felt a
stronger sense of love and belonging by
sharing my truth rather than hiding it
and struggling to maintain illusion with
my parent support I end the relationship
and apply to the new school and look at
me now this isn't to say that things are
always perfect but trust me they're so
much better I have found my voice I mean
breaking new possibilities and deeper
more meaningful relationships if I had
remained silent two years ago I would
have shut myself off from everything I'm
experiencing now acknowledging the code
of silence was a wake-up call for me I
learned it the hard way and I don't want
you to have to go through anything
similar my greatest hope is that you can
recognize those moments when a cop
speaking up may seem high but the cup of
silence is even greater and that you use
your voice to prevent yourself from
never knowing what my husband have just
spoken up
what are you currently being silent
about what are you not expressing them I
open up new possibilities for you your
relationship with others and perhaps
more importantly in your relationship
with yourself I encourage you to find
your voice thank you
[Applause]
[Music]